e per un grande canale ci vuole un
grande computer ben altri ragazzi venuti
a questo nuovo video io sono gay e
questi sono i ragazzi di prodi chic che
oggi mi aiuteranno a elevare la potenza
del mio canale con la bild di un nuovo
pc gaming completamente fatto da zero e
gli darete una mano a farlo perché io
non contare niente
il passo prima di costruire questo
computer abbiamo vedere il mio studio
perché faremo un primo dopo la mia
postazione da game milione venite con me
allora chiamata la cosa migliore che c'è
questa è la mia sedia che tenteremo
perché fa abbastanza schifo ma a parte
questo vediamo a livello di computer
abbiamo quindi un secondo computer
perché io per fare streaming utilizzo
due computer attualmente questo fa
invece lo porta a torino nei miei
genitori in europa lo usa per giocare a
scacchi il computer number one
quindi questo qua sarà quello nuovo che
monteremo adesso tra poco come setup è
abbastanza cm e medico immagino non
faccio così schifo ma non è neanche il
top e noi vogliamo ovviamente quello e
non vi ho fatto vedere a questo abbiamo
80 si pacchi contenenti i componenti del
computer è la sedia da gaming e andremo
adescato l'harley e montati questo gol
[Musica]
un bel logo personalizzato cassano e
abbiamo la nostra attrezzatura
all'interno di questo sport c'è un po di
spazio che mettiamo tutti pezzi molto
quindi non porterà ad ora non mettiamo
il caso la mettiamo prima questa è la
prima quella scheda madre sta roba
posso dirvi le cose che farei senza che
voi mi diciate niente niente gioco per i
veri che c'è un problema di formalmente
basta quale la ram trova il processore
cosa che manca è la scheda video tipo è
allora un po più qui
qui mammamia genero andrei via solo di 5
punti in più al diploma
non sono il tipo da rivolti malizia
partiamo dalla ram è che questa che è
una fantastica speck tricks di 50 kenya
prossimo nome di youtube viene ai 4 32gb
abbiamo 16 giga di ram in mano sai qual
è la cosa più importante di queste rom
saperla inserire alle luci il verso
giusto
dai ragazzi calabra non abbia paura
contro si rompe comunque non è difficile
contare un computer se lo fate voi c
detto lance c'è la cosa più delicata di
cui tutti hanno sempre più paura mettere
processore intel core i9 sbloccato
perché gli altri erano cioè non possono
aprirsi e bloccato vuol dire che poi per
col carbone non so se lo voglio perché
lo faremo rinascere scatola escludono
dire questo è il più potente in terra al
momento sul mercato che va rimosso
no quello si rimuove da solo ti dirò di
più rimuovi t la donna c'è un angolino
su col processore la cedevolezza per
quello c'è uno che becca non ha un dc10
di come non la vendo la vedo io
entrando entrato i ragazzi non si muove
lo dicono il contrario cyberpunk 2077
questo non mi so che cosa si aprono me
lo dite 3 di nando nand 3d c'è scritto
comunque va bene non c'è niente sempre
vuoto no c'è qualcosa non lo vedo anche
farlo ma questo non so più cosa sia non
me lo dire aspettà ram scheda madre
scheda video e non è questa l ssd è
ormai disintegrato la piuttosto pesanti
[Musica]
follia
adesso deciso di montare supera
quell'altra cosa di te lo tieni ssd
l'anti muoverai mai più quel che
possiamo fare altre cose
le tre ventolone le dobbiamo levare
perché poi ci andranno quelle delle vere
equatore poi entra varia che spinge
dentro ai 100 discutere che butta può
arrivare da qua sopra
e questa ventola che butta fuori l'aria
calda che si forma qua tutto
divertentissime radicalmente ricetta
ventole ritiene fresco il professor a
non capisco niente quello vettore del
nonno ma al radiatore questo qua dentro
scorre il liquido e questo lo dobbiamo
montare qua davanti mi servono le
vittone che c'erano dentro e questo va
sopra il processore con in mezzo la
pasta termica
ok va bene ma da una ragazza nostre
compagne tengono che siamo scesi
insegnate di avere in mano un radiatore
un'altra saying di uomo a bando da terra
le paste river tipo è sembrato che non
deve essere trasferito da il processore
al serbatoio la pasta conduce carbonio e
temi diversi che più efficaci mi sembra
chiaro quello che stai dicendo che
sentiva dagli affari ragazzi un
avvitatore lo portava recitato e
bellissimo l'abito chiamatemi che io
abito come ho fatto a vivere senza e non
ha mai abitato niente tra l'altro però
mi serve sarebbe raviglia gay che hai
fatto prima come è da che parte così no
così esatto
[Musica]
nel momento del pastore no pensante
commettere io non faccio cose di ste
robe lì e che questo tipo di pasta e poi
questo va applicato sull'operazione in
si spalma e quindi poi conduce su questa
piastra e con luce e calore
l'unica cosa che c'è di divertente
ancora da fare è mettere la scheda video
e resto è tutto è noioso quindi mettiamo
questa incredibile graphicar di gaming
three oggi paul celtics 30 70
questa scheda grafica ti permette di
giocare videogiochi di giocare a scacchi
con un rx acceso venete dove di pezzi
con il riflesso eccola dsss dark souls
sono diplomi super sempre una tecnologia
che permette di aver giocare in quattro
ko comunque a risoluzioni più alte
usando le reti xe ammortizzando con le
parti di decadimento di performance che
ti dà appunto la tecnologia il ray
tracing pesa 3 tonnellate e questo le fa
pesare meno di ls essere fatto in serie
b di viggiù e la o sono veramente
soddisfatto
non mettiamo questo che è
l'alimentazione un modello da 851 70
plus gold
tutte cose che non sto capendo niente di
oltre c'è una bella borsa guarda
un'altra ventola e bestack ora dobbiamo
mettere qua sotto
ci sarà mai il piano attaccare tutti i
cavi e alimentare tutto il pci e poi
abbiamo fatto
[Musica]
poco che non basta per questo sto
facendo io
togli musica
[Musica]
ha servito bene a te buttata nel cesso
ciao bene lo mettiamo i monitor nuovi
[Musica]
già qui e tu puoi passare tipo con l'u20
80 installata puoi buttare tutto al
massimo raytracing ultra molto rigido
per tutto qua tutto alto altri
tantissimo troppi come l'ancora poi
anche per paolo ii iii iv v al dlss ma
che nessuno le stesse dove mai
lome polita ovviamente tutto acceso emma
monitor a 164 65 hearts vanno a bomba
anche a posto così e di lasciar giocare
altro assai per pantaleo nel giardino
bella la mia ruota questa carta siamo
qui a porta che aveva un casino poi gli
archi ortì la porta grazie ci vediamo
tra una settimana anche due
[Musica]